and here's the latest that what we have
from Florida today we have new
information about those terrifying
moments before one of the deadliest
school shootings in US history does
rampages of parents in shock and a South
Florida community in agony today police
say their former student killed 17
people and wounded more than a dozen
others in Marjory Stoneman Douglas high
school that's in parkland and sadly
we've just learned the names of two of
the victims Jamie Guttenberg was a
student at the high school her brother
Jesse reportedly attended the same
school he made it home safely assistant
football coach and security guard Aaron
Feist was also killed in the shooting he
was actually shielding students from the
gunman when he was shot the suspect 19
year-old Nicholas Cruz was charged with
17 counts of premeditated murder this
morning after being taken to the Broward
County Jail officials say crews bought
an ar-15 semiautomatic rifle and several
magazines he brought them to the school
he also wore a gas mask and carried
smoke grenades CBS Evening News anchor
Jeff Glor is at the school in Parkland
which is northwest of Fort Lauderdale
Jeff good morning John good morning to
you this remains a busy if numb scene
today this is a huge campus more than 10
buildings attend classroom buildings
behind us more than 3,000 students
investigators work throughout the night
here as we've watched gathering evidence
at Stoneman Douglas high which remains a
crime scene it'll be closed today and
tomorrow all school activities are
canceled to the rest of this week police
say the gunman started his rampage
outside the school then went inside and
fired more shots hundreds of students
fled
police say the shooter concealed himself
in the crowd and was seen running out of
the school those who did not flee were
trapped in their classrooms some of them
saw classmates die right in front of him
many of the horrific moments were
captured on cell phone cameras we do
want to warn you some of the footage
you're about to see is graphic
the gunshot started ripping through
Marjorie Stoneman Douglas High School
around 2:30 p.m. Wednesday a heavy
police response arrived minutes later
the suspected gunman was identified as
Nicholas Cruz a 19 year old who had been
expelled from the school he allegedly
began the rampage outside where two
people died once inside carrying a gas
mask and smoke bombs Cruz apparently
pulled a fire alarm causing chaos then
began shooting 12 people died inside the
school Broward County Sheriff Scott
Israel he had countless magazines
multiple magazines and at this point
[Music]
police were able to track his movements
in part using the school's surveillance
cameras he was captured about an hour
after he allegedly first opened fire
SWAT teams then went room to room
clearing the school frightened students
ran down hallways stepping over
discarded backpacks you heard up and
down the hallway just banging and
shooting into the classrooms he shot
through my door and broke the window
the suspect posted photos of knives and
guns on Instagram in a voice mail sent
to parents in Palm Beach County Robert
of OSA the superintendent there asked
parents and students if they see
something - say something
if the account are correct this
individual was posting things on social
media that should have been a red flag
Broward County superintendent Robert
Runcie words cannot express the sorrow
that we feel no parent should ever have
to send their kids to school and have
them not returned we've got to find a
way
for this to stop state flags in Florida
at half-staff this morning to honor
those who died in this shooting
yesterday president Trump offered
sympathy on Twitter adding quote no
child teacher anyone else should ever
feel unsafe in an American school